خطوه طال انتظارها لكنها ضروريه لتحقيق
العداله والمحاسبه بالنسبه للعائله بعد
سته اشهر من مقتل الصحفيه الفلسطينيه
شيرين ابو عقل والهجوم على نعشها تعمل
وعائلتها ان يكون تحقيق الامريكي مستقلا
وشاملا وذا مصداقيه
هذه خطوه مهمه عائلتنا طالبت بتحقيق
امريكي منذ البدايه والسلطات الامريكيه
تتحمل مسؤوليه اجراء تحقيق عندما يقتل
مواطن الامريكي في الخارج خصوصا عندما تتم
عمليه القتل بايدي جيش اجنبي كما هو الحال
بالنسبه لشيرين لكن التحقيق خطا فادح
بالنسبه لاسرائيل التي ترفض الاعتراف به
او المشاركه فيه
ارسلت رساله الى ممثلين الولايات المتحده
مفادها اننا نقف الى جانب جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي واننا لا نتعاون مع اي تحقيق
خارجي كما لن نسمح بالتدخل في التحقيقات
الداخليه
امريكي
من الرصاص عليها علامه صحافه عندما
استهدفت برصاصه في راسها خلال عمليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه
الجيش اعلى في الخامس من سبتمبر الماضي ان
احد جنوده اطلق النار بالخطا على ابو عقله
لكنه رفض محاكمته فيما تعتبر العائله ان
شيرين استهدفت عمدا كجزء من حرب اسرائيليه
واسعه نطاق على الاعلاميين الفلسطينيين